Hello, my name is Reto Meier,
and welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Monday
August 5, 2013.
Last week, I waved my hands
around in a sign of unbridled
excitement as I introduced
Android 4.3, an exciting
gourmet flavor of jelly
bean available for
your development pleasure.
Stefan and took a deeper dive
into one of these new Android
4.3 features with a look at the
new UI Automation Testing
Tool Kit, while Ankur continued
his series of making
apps beautiful with a glance
back at backwards
compatibility and a fresh new
take on modernization.
Not to be outdone, Chet did some
stretching and squashing,
and also recorded a DevByte
on animation.
The July Android Developer
Survey closed last week with
6,000 Android developers
sharing their thoughts.
It was no surprise to see the US
developers account for the
largest number of responses.
But which country do you think
filled the number two spot?
The Google Play Games Services
team had found an ingenious
way to ensure that they have
more time for playing games by
having you do their jobs for
them with the launch of the
public bug tracker for Google
Play Game Services.
Join them this week for another
episode of Game On
where they'll be taking you
through the process of saving
game state to the cloud.
Our European colleagues joined
the Paris Android user group
for what I'm sure was a
debaucherous event filled with
fine wine, soft cheeses, and
some Android development, or
at least that's what their
expense report suggests.
Coming up this week, JF is back
with a breakdown of how
to detect Overdraw using
the Hierarchy Viewer.
And Nick the Butcher has
prepared some find cuts of
aged and marbled design bytes,
starting this week with a look
at responsive design.
Not to be outdone, keep an eye
out for the latest from Chet
as he delves into the magical
world of cartoon animation
techniques.
Also this week, our Australian
advocates will be hosting the
second part of their Making Apps
Beautiful backstage show.
Join them to ask questions on
how you can make your apps a
little more magical.
That's all for this week
in Android Development.
Be sure to check out this week's
Dev and Design bytes
and know that I'll set fire
to your new shoes.